[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi 4
octobre l'événement a fait le clan golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
quelques jours après la fin de la ryder
cup
quel premier bilan dressé en matière de
tourisme le rendez vous at il été
bénéfique également pour l'ile-de-france
ses hôtels et ses sites éléments de
réponse avec christophe de cloud
directeur général du comité régional du
tourisme paris ile de france a redonné
confiance aux personnes dans le besoin
depuis septembre les bénéficiaires des
restos du coeur de rambouillet peuvent
profiter des services d'une coiffeuse
elle délocalise son salon une fois par
semaine dans les locaux de l'association
et propose des coupes gratuite
enfin c'est une première dans l'histoire
du club de baseball les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux sont en finale du
championnat de france de division 1
match 1 et 2 au programme ce week end à
rouen les yvelinois qui disputeront
également une coupe d'europe nous en
parlons avec nos invités
les députés viennent de donner leur feu
vert l'assemblée nationale autorise la
privatisation du groupe aéroports de
paris l état détient actuellement un peu
plus de 50% des parts de adp pour
quelques 9,5 milliards d'euros dans les
yvelines l'entreprise gère les
aérodromes de toussus-le-noble saint cyr
l'école et chavenay villepreux une
privatisation rendue possible par la
future loi pacte qui n'obligera plus
l'état à détenir la majorité des parts
du groupe aéroportuaire
on accueille sur ce plateau notre
première invitée à christophe de cloud
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
général du comité régional du tourisme
paris ile de france alors on va dresser
avec vous dans un instant un premier
bilan touristique de la ryder cup juste
avant est depuis la fin de l'événement
dimanche dernier les organisateurs ont
commencé à démonter les gigantesques
structures
l opération devrait durer plusieurs
semaines les détails de michael et me
d'euros le jeudi 27 septembre golf
national accueillait la cérémonie
d'ouverture de la ryder cup ait plus de
40000 spectateurs dans le public
une semaine plus tard l'atmosphère a
bien changé les fans ont laissé la place
à des ouvriers pour les pros
mir opérations de démontage c'est
bizarre c'est étrange on est plein plein
plein de différentes émotions on a des
hauts et des débats parce que ça s'est
passé tellement vite
et vu de l'intérieur on n'a pas vraiment
vu par ckoi au total 300 personnes sont
présentes sur le site pour enlever au
plus vite les structures le dernier
camion devrait repartir à la mi novembre
là actuellement sur le parcours ce matin
il ya des gradins qui ont déjà disparu
derrière le 17
c'est en plein démontage derrière le 14e
trou numéro 14
les grandes gradins public sont déjà
démonté il y a évidemment des camions
qui sont déjà partis des camions burger
et cetera
je dirais un quart a déjà disparu les
fans de golf peuvent tout de même être
rassuré tout ne sera pas démonté ou
enlever le golf national devrait garder
des stickers de la compétition sur
certains murs le vestiaire de la team
europe sera lui aussi conservé dans son
intégralité
christophe de cloud est avec moi
emplettes au directeur général du comité
régional du tourisme paris ile de france
alors le crt étaient présents sur cette
ryder cup vous aviez vous aviez un stand
dédié
comment vous l'avez vécu de l'intérieur
cette ryder cup a déjà des de dire que
la gaule immense fierté pour dire la
france et la région parisienne
d'accueillir le troisième événement
sportif du monde juste après les jo et
les et la coupe du monde de football
donc c'est vraiment une immense fierté
de pouvoir montrer au monde entier de la
capacité de la france et de la région
pour accueillir ce type d'événement nous
on a vécu on avait un instant de la
région au sein du pavillon france sur le
parvis central juste devant la scène où
il ya eu la cérémonie d'ouverture et de
zèle ou nous avons eu beaucoup de monde
américain anglais en particulier qui
sont dus nous nous voir pour mieux
connaître la destination golfique de la
région où nous avons pu leur donner pas
mal d'informations en sachant que nous
avons 60 plus de 70 golfe
en ile-de-france les possibilités
golfique dans un instant leurs soixante
mille spectateurs environ par jour sur
place on sait que les bénéfices en
termes de billetterie de merchandising
iront à l'organisateur de l'événement il
est aussi les retombées indirectes
hôtellerie visites de sites transport et
est ce que la région ile-de-france a
profité de ce grand événement alors
qu'il est encore trop tôt pour voir tous
les chiffres mais on a déjà des de
certaines tendances sur la perception
par les professionnels de la ryder cup
on est à plus de 95 % de satisfaits de
la période de la semaine dernière deux
pendant la ryder cup
nous avons également constaté une forte
augmentation des visiteurs anglais
américains qui sont arrivés par avion ou
par par l'eurostar sur sur la
destination
les hôtels aux alentours du golf ont
fait le plein en fait le plein mais ça
rayonner jusqu'à dans paris ou même nos
galas la petite couronne parisienne
alors la france tablait avant avant
l'événement sur 220 millions d'euros de
retombées économiques c'est un objectif
qui pourrait être atteint souvent en
apparence c'est ce qu'ont c'était
l'objectif
maintenant on n'a pas encore toujours
avoir ce qu'on a vu en revanche c'est
que la restauration a bien fonctionné
lors de la ryder cup et des très tôt le
matin donc sur tout le parcours avec les
60000 personnes qui sont venues assister
aux autos parcours sur l'allée journée
de jeudi vendredi et samedi et dimanche
je vous le disiez sur place des
américains et des britanniques
selon canal+ nos confrères de canal+ y
avait eu également beaucoup de français
40 % du public présent à la ryder cup
aurait été français c'est sûrement vrai
au monde sait que 7% à peu près des des
visiteurs étaient américains et donc est
donc le reste était europe du nord
évidemment en angleterre mais ça va tout
le royaume uni avec les cuirs landes et
d'allant du nord
vous l'avez dit il est trop tôt pour
avoir ces chiffres et ce bilan final est
et ce qu'on sait en revanche sur les
réservations si les personnes présentes
à l'arrêt dans quatre sont venus
exclusivement pour cet événement où son
voilà partis sur des séjours plus longs
sur la région ile de france
on a eu plus de nuitées qu'auparavant au
mois de septembre qui est pas une
on est très très important au niveau
touristique ans dans la région donc oui
on a eu plus de nuitées et des pam a
beaucoup de visiteurs qui sont venus
pour la semaine et donc ont découvert
d'autres d'autres sites
on était proche saint quentin en
yvelines et proche du château de
versailles par exemple donc les surtout
ceux qui viennent des états unis donc
avec dès les heures de vol ont bénéficié
de de l'accueil et des sites
touristiques en ile-de-france d'ailleurs
si on rappelle très très rapidement les
possibilités en termes de tourisme en
ile de france
on est dans une région il ya de l'urbain
il ya la campagne voilà les possibilités
sont grandes
le comité régional de tourisme propose
d'ailleurs un pass pour la région
ile-de-france alors vous venez me lance
et on l'a lancée pour la ryder cup le
pari ce budget n'est pas ce qui est une
carte sans contact qui intègre le
transport en commun sur toute l'île de
france mais également des croisières sur
la seine des bus touristiques les fameux
open au plf qui sont à paris mais
également la visite l'accès à plus de 60
musée en ile de france
est ce qu'on peut espérer aussi avec ce
parcours de l'albatros qui a été en
mondiovision que la destination golf
française va se développer que l'île de
france va devenir une région golfique de
tourisme golfique là nous on fait tout
pour parce qu'évidemment on va surfer
sur la ryder cup sur le sur un parc sai
mondialement on lance également un début
2019 le paraissent vides jeunes golf à
ce qui permettra à nos visiteurs
internationaux de venir pour jouer au
golf dans la dans la région avec une
facilité de réservation des impasses qui
permet d'avoir jusqu'à -20% sud de
réduction sur les greens fille est donc
devenir évidemment golf et là où la
ryder cup s'est passé donc au boss
nationale mais également sur une
vingtaine d'autres golfs partenaires en
ile-de-france veut dire quoi
concrètement pourrait faire un neuf
trous le matin allée visiter pourquoi
pas le château de versailles l'après
midi c'est exactement ça c'est ce qu'on
sait ce qu'on souhaite c'est déjà un que
les b on n'abandonne pas le site je ne
lève pas son à deux ou quatre boeufs à
choisir selon la formule choisie est
donc évidemment quand on vient pendant
quatre cinq jours une semaine à à paris
c'est de découvrir là
la région voire évidemment l'ouest parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de golf de dans
l'ouest francilien mais également les
halles est aussi du doigt les revisiter
fontainebleau voulait musée de la grande
guerre à mot par exemple il ya 410 mille
licenciés de en golf en france et le 11e
pays au classement mondial dans la
région parisienne c'est quoi les
possibilités vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est plus de 70 golf 71 71
exactement donc après fait déjà beaucoup
de franciliens qui est qui genou ce qui
nous intéresse c'est de faire venir des
visiteurs internationaux qui sont
globalement d aider des clients si on
peut les appeler comme ça premium et qui
ont plus de consommateurs consomment
plus dans notre région faut savoir que
sur 1 sur des des joueurs de golf ils
peuvent revenir sur une destination
trois quatre fois sur la même
destination pour découvrir plusieurs
golfs dans une région par exemple si on
devait faire le bilan de cet entretien
est ce que la ryder cup selon vous va
laisser une empreinte durable pour la
région ile-de-france pour le tourisme
golfique dans la région ile-de-france a
même nom dont on est pendant les
persuader sa raison pour laquelle ans
plusieurs passes plusieurs parcours
golfique pour pour surfer si on peut
utiliser ce nouveau round un golf sur ce
qui s'est passé et on son expert aussi
qu'on pourrait être candidat pour une
prochaine ryder cup ici c'était la
première en france la deuxième en europe
depuis qu'elle est ouverte au delà de
l'angleterre
donc oui la la il appela perception
qu'auront nos visiteurs internationaux
pour le parcours golfique et est un vrai
atout pour la région et bientôt aussi
une nouvelle exposition avec cette
épreuve de djo qui arrivera en 2024 les
épreuves de golf pour les jeux
olympiques 2024 à paris et aussi à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci avec
christophe de trévoux d'avoir été avec
nos directeur général du comité régional
du tourisme paris ile de france pour
avoir plus d'informations sur le
tourisme en ile de france je vous invite
à consulter le site internet qui
s'affiche à il s'affiche en bas de
l'écran solidarité connu pour sa
campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur se
donne une mission plus large c'est de
redonner le sourire et la confiance à
leurs bénéficiaires est depuis septembre
un salon de coiffure a ouvert à
rambouillet un salon de coiffure
délocalise son activité à l'antenne des
restos du coeur et ce une fois par
semaine un reportage de marie line yapi
chinois
es tu
la plus belle du monde
aucune autre
le mardi après midi dans les locaux des
restos du coeur de rambouillet les
coupes sanchez
la gérante du salon sourire diam's a
contacté l'association il ya trois ans
pour proposer ses services
deux séances ponctuelles elle est passée
cette année un créneau hebdomadaire
consacrée aux bénéficiaires et des
personnes qui aident avec des dons il ya
des personnes qui aident financièrement
et puis moi je voulais vraiment aider
avec notre savoir faire car je pars
vraiment sur le principe que être beau
pour un entretien est beau tout les
jours ben ça redonne confiance en soi et
c'est aussi ma façon de collaborer aux
citoyens de rambouillet l'une de ses
employées vient tous les mardis de 14 à
16 heures pour quoi faire en moyenne
cinq bénéficiaires gratuitement
raccourcir la longueur la neige je ne
suis pas habitué aux séances rico du
mardi après-midi organisé par le resto
du coeur de rambouillet marie laure a
cette fois décidé de passer entre les
mains d'audrey un moment pour soi idéal
pour se sentir en confiance avant son
prochain entretien en bouche on perd
beaucoup son emploi au pied autre chose
et on est dans une situation jusqu'à
aller aux restos du coeur ça veut dire
que mais financièrement on n'y arrive
plus belles images loossoise c'est très
très important et toujours le sourire
pour la famille pour nous mêmes
les bénéficiaires sont ravis d'avoir
accès à ce service et les sciences quoi
sur d'autres et sont déjà complètes
jusqu'au mois de novembre
[Musique]
comme chaque jeudi le portrait de la
rédaction il vient de prendre sa
retraite après dix ans de service alain
salomé était le responsable de la police
municipale de voisins-le-bretonneux nous
l'avons rencontré lors de ses dernières
patrouille l'occasion de revenir sur sa
carrière portrait signé patrick jacques
de dixmude et nicolas landry bon les
gars pour ce matin françois et gaël vous
ferez une patrouille pédestre en
priorisant les contacts commerçants
c'est l'une des dernières consignes
données à ces hommes alain salomé
responsable de la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux va prendre sa
retraite dans quelques jours en restant
en liaison radio
pour l'instant il part en patrouille
avec rémy dans une zone pavillonnaire de
la commune dans les zones pavillonnaires
notre présence est quand même
indispensable dans la journée
car les gens sont travail laisse la
maison vide jusque ce soir une
dissuasion qui peut parfois mener à
l'intervention les policiers municipaux
vie si noah ont dû mener une opération
sur le cambriolage d'une maison par
plusieurs individus
notre arrivée sur façon
les interpellés en flagrant délit avec
les 6 av
est fracturée
une porte fenêtre en pvc
et à bien
la maison l'intérieur arrivé à la police
municipale de voisins-le-bretonneux en
tant que stagiaire en 2001 alain salomé
a gravi des échelons jusqu'à devenir
responsable en 2005 après avoir été
gendarme pendant près de 20 ans en 99
j'avais passé le concours de la police
municipale parce qu'elle ait pas de
passerelle à l'époque vous pouvez pas
passer de la gendarmerie et à la police
municipale donc j'ai passé le congo
l'échelle de la commune est très
intéressante pour tout ce qui est pour
d'actes et renseignements auprès de la
population contact auprès des citoyens
plusieurs dossiers municipaux comme
l'obtention des pistolets à impulsion
électrique ou encore l'installation de
la vidéo protection
avec un marché conclu avant son départ
pour la remise à niveau des caméras sur
trois ans arrivé à 57 caméras dont dont
pas mal de caméras en lecture de plaques
qui nous permet de visualiser les
véhicules qui rentre et qui sortait des
quartiers donc ça très intéressant pour
le aussi sur les camps volage avec cinq
agents la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux est une véritable
famille pour alain salomé je pense
qu'ils sont quand même satisfait de 2,2
de mon commandement mais j'avais pomme
même passé un commandement c'est naturel
c'est une personne très humaine qui
qui fait preuve de très grande
compétence pour attribuer les missions
et aussi comment exécuter les missions
parce que des fois c'est vrai qu'il faut
prendre des dispositions sur certaines
interventions il a toujours su nous nous
diriger dans le bon sens au bout de 17
ans qu est-ce qu on est content
j'imagine d'être à la retraite et en
même temps on est content mais je lâche
une équipe quoi après 17 ans de service
le néo-retraité va pouvoir en profiter
notamment chez lui à rambouillet et dans
un pays qu'il apprécie particulièrement
l'espagne sport un club saint quentinois
à une marche une seule du titre national
en baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux sont en finale du championnat
de france de division 1 c'est le plus
haut niveau national match 1 et 2 au
programme ce week-end à l'extérieur
contre les huskys de rouen alors pour en
parler en plateau deux invités rodolphe
le meur bonsoir l'entraîneur des
couguars de montigny le bretonneux et
dylan mahieu bonsoir entraîneur joueur
de ce club alors c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire du club que voilà vous
atteignez cette finale on imagine c'est
quelque chose d'énorme pour pour les
cougars et c'est une grande satisfaction
c'est vrai que ça fait 30 ans que le
club existe on fait en plus
l'anniversaire 7 cette année et ça tombe
à point nommé d'atteindre ce niveau et
d'être au final de ce championnat de
division 1 dylan jouer une finale
nationale ça ça représente quoi pour un
joueur pour un joueur c'est tout ce
qu'on attend pendant toute la saison on
se prépare tout l'hiver pour jouer des
grandes compétitions comme comme celle
ci ensuite je pense que voilà on est
tous prêts on n'attend que ça en
attendant de savoir si vous remportez
cette finale une chose est assurée c'est
que les cougars participeront un
championnat d'europe et une coupe
d'europe les prochaines jouer une coupe
d'europe aussi c'est quelque chose
d'énorme
c'est quelque chose dont j'ai la chance
de le faire avec un autre club
c'est sûr que c'est une marche au dessus
à gravir
je pense que vu l'équipe qu'on a et ce
qu'on vise
je pense que c'est réalisable pour
l'année prochaine en tout cas de figure
on le précise vous pourrez disputer une
coupe d'europe
ah si vous remportez ce titre national
donc avec les meilleures équipes dans le
cas contraire ça serait une coupe
d'europe b alors vous faisiez face vous
faites face pardon ce week-end aux
huskys de rouen les huskys de ronces et
treize titres lors des quinze dernières
saisons en d1 c'est un duel de david
contre goliath qui s'annonce c'est vrai
quoi c'est une grosse machine qui c'est
qui sait conclure ces championnats qui a
toujours été au rendez vous et qui a
trait ce titre à son nom à son tableau
c'est vrai que oui on peut dire on peut
dire ça c'est pourtant cette saison je
suis je suis un peu plus confiants que
les années précédentes il avait battu
deux fois lors de la saison régulière
fois on les a battus au challenge de
france
on les a mis en doute on les a fait
douter donc on peut encore les faire
douter mais voilà ça reste quand même
une grosse machine grosse machine pardon
essayer c'est un des clubs phares du
club du baseball français pardon rien
n'est joué d'avancé mais il ya peut-être
un avantage au niveau mental vous avez
battu cette équipe deux fois cette
saison
déjà alors l'a battu deux fois à
français on sait à quoi s'attendre là
c'est pas le championnat ce cd phase
finale donc on sait qu il va falloir se
renforcer à tous les matchs alors match
1 et 2 au programme ce week-end ce sera
à l'extérieur vous recevrez match trois
quatre peut être cinq à
montigny-le-bretonneux recevoir est ce
que c'est un réel avantage recevoir en
dernier recevrait en dernier c'est un
avantage
moi oui après on va dire que chacun a sa
façon de penser je pense que finir à la
maison c'est quand même quelque chose
parce qu'on connaît le terrain on
connaît on n'a plus de repères que ce qu
on y passe beaucoup de temps après bon
je pense qu'il ya certaines personnes
qui voient pas d'inconvénient à
l'extérieur alors de cette saison
régulière vous avez terminé troisième
après avoir passé les quarts de finale
en 2000 il ya eu cet exploit contre
montpellier 1 3 0 infligé à montpellier
qui a fini premier de la saison
régulière racontez-nous rodolphe un peu
cette sensation comment comment elle
s'est déroulée cette sensation a été
rendue possible
on est parti vraiment
renforcée ont enfin on y est vraiment
déterminés c'est vrai que comme disait
dylan le les les phases finales sont
vraiment différente du championnat de la
saison régulière et on était vraiment
vraiment déterminés à aller plus loin
donc c'est vrai qu'on a rencontré une
équipe qui a fini premiers de ce
championnat
on y est allés serein mais quand même on
voulait donner vraiment un maximum sur
ses sources et les trois matches faire
le script ce qu'on appelle le sweep
s'est promenée trois matches sur cinq
d'un coup c'était pas une surprise mais
on a été vraiment enfin moi j'ai quand
j'ai vu mais mes gars jouer sur le
terrain je les ai sentis vraiment ils se
sont transcendés sûr c'est sur ces trois
matches là et après après le deuxième
match je sentais vraiment qu'on pouvait
conclure sur une troisième victoire
rapidement oui il ya une confiance qui a
été acquise la sueur sur ces quarts et
demi-finales ne sais pas comment c'est
venu mais c'est vrai qu'entre les quarts
et est-ce qu'on a joué en 2000 à ces
deux équipes différentes on est
surmotivé ça fonctionne et daf le maire
vous êtes arrivé il ya deux ans et ça
aux cougars de montigny non j'y suis
depuis plusieurs années j'ai pris en
tant qu'entraîneur j'ai pris l'équipe de
division 1 il ya deux ans oui très bien
alors depuis le club a grandi cette
finale nationale qui est la première
dans l'histoire du club
comment on commence a été rendue star
été rendu possible le fait d'atteindre
ce stade mais il ya eu un gros travail
c'est vrai depuis deux ans depuis la
montée en division
on a fait beaucoup de recrutements on a
sur ses structures et aussi on a créé
une direction sportive qui a pris en
charge dans toutes ses phases de
recrutement qui sont importantes ce que
d augmenter d'une division vous avez
vous êtes très sollicité donc il faut
faire le tri il faut savoir prendre les
bons joueurs il faut aller aussi
chercher des joueurs à l'étranger parce
que c'est essentiel pour jouer en
division 1 et tout ce travail de
recrutement
il a été vraiment vraiment efficace et
puis tout le travail hivernal qu'on peut
faire avec les avec les joueurs on a
vraiment mis des choses en place un peu
plus dur on sait on sait que en division
1 vous devez monter un cran supérieur
donc les entraînements ont été aussi
élever d'un cran supérieur donc voilà
tout ça ça a vraiment fonctionné cette
partie recrutement cette partie
préparation est là elle a vraiment été
efficace et aujourd'hui on a on a le
fruit de nos efforts et les quelques
jours qui précèdent cette grande finale
il ressemble à quoi est ce que la
préparation est un peu différente
comment comment vous avez préparé vos
joueurs nous on se prépare de façon à
pouvoir être prêt sur le terrain après
on révise plus on n'est plus dans le
détail de la perfection et réviser ce
qui nous a rapporté défaut pendant la
saison mais sinon on n'y a pas de choses
différentes particulièrement pendant les
entraînements
un petit mot pour vous deux pour
terminer il ya de la pression dans vos
rangs dans l'impression c'est ce que
j'ai dit une interview avec moi la
pression je préfère la voir que de la
subir et on y va sereinement voilà on a
vraiment aujourd'hui le contrat il est
rempli l'objectif n'est pas encore
atteint mais le contrat est rempli
on voulait faire mur c'est ce qu'on
s'était dit avec les joueurs en début de
saison on voulait faire mieux que la la
demi finale l'année dernière
le contrat est rempli maintenant voilà
l'objectif c'est là c'est le titre et on
va aller on va les chercher même état
d'esprit dylan par ailleurs on dit que
une finale ça se gagne ça joue pas donc
alors nous tous déterminés ont besoin
jusqu'au bout quand on vous souhaite
bonne chance pour cette finale on y
reviendra dans nos éditions de la
semaine prochaine merci à vous rodolphe
le meur et dylan mahieu avoir été avec
nous et je rappelle que les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux sont en finale du
championnat de france 2 a dit un match 1
et 2
au programme ce week-end à rouen culture
en 1945 le journaliste henri calet
publiait les murs de fresnes
un ouvrage inventaire des inscriptions
gravées par les prisonniers résistants
français ou étrangers pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale est de ce témoignage la
compagnie ma belle octobre en fait un
projet transmédia c'est un spectacle
interactif où le spectateur devient
acteur à la compagnie était en résidence
au prisme à elancourt et à la présenter
l'avancée de son projet à mélanie poké
avec murs de fresnes
on ne vous demandera pas de couper votre
téléphone bien au contraire
le spectateur est comme un narrateur la
compagnie mâts bell'occas vous fait
vivre de l'intérieur le quotidien des
résistants enfermé en 39 45
[Musique]
c'est la question du choix
à l'époque c'est la question du choix
quel toit faisait ton bac l import ce
mais de quel bord quel bord choisissent
et on est ce qu on dit souvent que les
français ont été très résistant mais en
fait ils ont été massivement à partir de
quel épisode va suivre en fonction du
vote que vous avez à d'effectuer
puisqu'il ya plusieurs mots qui relie
plusieurs épisodes des mots clés comme
amour tortures arrestations
régulièrement vous pouvez aussi
interagir directement sur le plateau
d'on par exemple qu'en japonais nier ce
fait interroger on peut c'est le public
qui décide de lui donner des coups cinq
personnages sont actuellement créer des
personnages réels louis jaconelli
huguette preniez robert beck et gaston
daoust et berty albrecht la compagnie ma
belle octobre a entrepris un long
travail de recherche avec un point de
départ mur de fresnes du journaliste
henri kaleki publié en 1945 qui est un
livre absolument étonnant qui compile
tous les graffitis qui ont été laissées
par les prisonniers au départ des
allemands pendant l'occupation pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale dont ouvrage
m'a d'abord donné un certain nombre de
graffitis et des indications sur quel
type de personnes avaient été arrêtées
et quel avait été leur destin et à
partir de ce fou de tous ces noms là
j'ai fait mon propre choix à l'intérieur
et j'ai fait des recherches
supplémentaires pour voir qu'il est
qu'elle avait été l'histoire de ces
personnes et qu'est ce qu'il en reste
est une immersion prenant porté par un
seul comédien mur de frêne est encore en
cours de création avec l'ajout de deux
autres personnages avant d'être reporté
sur scène
avant de se quitter il tentera demain
soir d'être le nouveau ninja warriors
originaire de la verrière louis boniface
est en finale du jeu de tf1
le principe franchir un parcours du
combattant en un minimum de temps le
jeune de 20 ans a terminé troisième de
sa demi-finale la semaine dernière en
une minute et 10 secondes c'est un féru
de gymnastique et de slackline et
disciplines liées au funambulisme que
vous voyez à l'image ils seront 25
candidats en lice pour cette ultime
étape finale à suivre à partir de 21h ce
vendredi sur tf1
c'est la fin de ce journal pour toutes
les idées de sorties du week-end je vous
invite à retrouver dans un instant le
7-8 loisirs présenté par marylène yapi
shiloh belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]